como ya hemos tratado varias veces en
este canal los sister ex como sabemos
son secretos que se esconden en muchas
de estas joyas que jugamos a diario y
que son los jugadores o bien con mucha
habilidad con mucha suerte pueden
encontrar la mayoría de veces se tratan
de secretos felices divertidos o incluso
a los efectos lo suficientemente locos
como para pensar que los desarrolladores
al momento de pensar en ellos enchufan
sustancias suculentamente adictivas y
justamente prohibidas por un tubo
si nuestra contento está
ah
pero en otros casos menos vistos a los
creadores del juego les gusta poner a
prueba nuestra capacidad de retener
líquidos mediante nuestros ojos al poner
los intereses más tristes que hagan
llorar cualquiera y ese será el motivo
por el cual nos reunamos en este vídeo y
seres tan tristes y desgarradores que
harían llorar hasta el más macho y la
mayoría tienen que ver algo con animales
pero hombres a ver son éstos las cosas
mil veces más tristes cuando involucran
animales nieguen ven no tengo pruebas
pero tampoco tengo dudas así que si tu
criatura triste y solitaria que sentirte
aún más triste o si tú que eres la
persona sin problemas que es tener tu
dosis diaria de lágrimas y tristeza que
empañó los a la mano y acompañada en
esta lista con los intereses más tristes
en videojuegos
[Música]
la depresión es un problema muy serio
que todos debemos darle la suficiente
importancia porque nunca sabemos lo que
pasa dentro de la mente de una persona y
por lo que está pasando y esto no lo
hemos tras el este de una manera
brillante celeste es un juego donde
tendrá la tarea de escalar una montaña
mientras que nuestra protagonista
madeleine sufre depresión y ataques de
ansiedad constantemente a lo largo de la
aventura no podemos saber qué es lo que
experimenta madeleine pero el juego en
cierta parte nos da la oportunidad de
hacerlo en el capítulo 5 si reproducimos
el audio que escuchamos de fondo al
revés podremos escuchar los pensamientos
más profundos de madeleine
[Música]
desde hace ya varios años jobs house es
conocida como aquella serie donde puedes
hacer todo tipo de estupideces que el
juego te permita para pasar de ello hay
un interés dentro de este alocado juego
que nos aguarda los ojos ya que dentro
del hermoso mapa que josh cause 4 nos
ofrece ahora una zona del mapa que
funcionara especialmente como memorial
para recordar a seres queridos que los
creadores del juego perdieron haciendo
de esta zona un gran homenaje para todos
ellos
[Música]
y el software es esa saga que nos
mantiene maravillados con acción pobre
momentos inolvidables pero que también
sabe cómo llegar al corazón como ya
saben una gran parte de la trama de kirk
se centra en la búsqueda de don por su
esposa maría que tristemente se
encontraron estado moribundo siendo don
la persona que más la ama en el mundo
quien tuvo que sacarla de su miseria
sus 2000
[Música]
acto que lo haría traumado y deprimido
al punto que eventualmente muera
sacrificándose por salvar a marcus y sus
compañeros y tener su tan anhelado
encuentro con marian dos de las escenas
más memorables de todos los videojuegos
en hyeres 4 decidieron hacerle honor a
uno de estos momentos en la campaña
eventualmente cruzarás por un cementerio
con las vías marcadas con letras que les
disparos en cierto orden a las lápidas
formando la palabra maria la niebla cura
todo el lugar y aparecerán unas luces
que si las sigues revivirás el triste
momento de la despedida de don y mariah
aquí te lo dejo completo
ría
[Música]
no no no no
robert smith a manex
esta manera
marquis
sí
qué
en su show
[Música]
un soso
al odioso
[Música]
e
ya
[Música]
estoy seguro que ya la gran mayoría
conoce la conmovedora historia de
hachiko o de bobby pero es que realmente
visitaban día tras día la tumba de su
amado dueño hasta el día de sus muertes
sino un extra historias como éstas más a
hamás de una lágrima mostrar la belleza
criaturas que son los animales son
historias maravillosas y en grande faltó
5 decidió rendir tributo a estas
historias si vas al cementerio
encontrarás que hay un perrito que día
tras día para leal y cariñosamente a
visitar a su dueño fallecido para pasar
tiempo con él cada día los animales son
las criaturas más puras y leales que hay
y cosas como esta nos ayudan a
recordarlo
[Música]
y nuevamente uno relacionado con
animales hey advertí al inicio el vídeo
ápex legend es uno de los juegos más
adictivos y más jugados en la actualidad
con tantas personas jugando
simultáneamente a este título no
tardaron mucho antes de encontrar los
intereses en sus mapas uno de estos
estar es que encontraron su misterio
saltar con fotos de una persona y de un
perro esto consultivas a los jugadores y
cuando se le preguntó a los
desarrolladores del juego acerca de
dichos térek esto fue lo que respondió
nuestra proyecta de 10 años murió por
problemas de salud mientras estaba
trabajando en 15 caña como cualquier
amante de los animales de saber esto fue
un golpe devastador para mi moral eso
que fuera muy difícil ir a trabajar se
hiciera nuestra mejor amiga así que
creía que ya vivir en este rincón del
mapa realmente más de sentir mejor vista
esta es una de vez en cuando
nuevamente los animales demostrar su
amor en condicionar yo importantes que
pueden ser para una persona cuando en
realidad masato mascotas se convierte en
parte de tu familia experimentar la
pérdida de tu mejor amigo puede ser muy
duro y es armaba súper thatcher y bueno
su mejor amiga murió quiso hacerle un
homenaje sino que seguir y nunca fuera
olvidada y viva por siempre en esta
parte del mapa
[Música]
la saga de gears of war hemos perdido a
muchos personajes y en gears 5 que son
rendirles homenaje a todos ellos a lo
largo la campaña principal podemos
recolectar bastantes coleccionables que
se en referencia a algún personaje caído
de la serie cuando llegamos al acto 4
podemos encontrar un mural en memoria
los caídos que parece momento hemos
recogido suficientes de estos
coleccionables podemos colocarlos en el
muro uno por uno
escuchando las voces de aquellos a
quienes pertenecían dichos objetos
cuando los coloquemos todos tendremos un
homenaje final a todos los héroes que
perdimos en esta saga
sí no
[Música]
el senado transversal
pero hay más
[Música]
esto
nadie
[Música]
bien
el presente
[Música]
la carpintería
mientras borda las dos estaba en
desarrollo la desarrolladora aquí el box
trascendió con movedor mensaje una
persona les contó que su amigo michael
mamario que era un gran fan de
borderlands desafortunadamente murió de
cáncer a los 22 años mientras esperaba
la salida de borderlands 2 el chico les
vio los creador del juego que por favor
nieguen un mensaje de cada maikel dicho
por claptrap para acordar su amigo en
gearbox from tan bondadosos que no sólo
hicieron esto sino que le dieron a
michael al juego con personaje no
jugador que puedes encontrar de vez en
cuando zhang shuai michael es un
personaje bondadoso que te recibirá
siempre gentilmente y te obsequia armas
cada vez que los aludes son brillo gesto
de parte de ir boxear puesto este
homenaje a michael para que siempre esté
inmortalizado en este juego pero que el
mensaje claptrap para michael
[Música]
con tránsito
col
el mismo señor arruinado
[Música]
especial
actitudes que entonces fórmulas
[Música]
vigón
muy similar al puesto anterior boston
beer you era el nickname de un jugador
de rainbows textil que lamentablemente
falleció a boston le gustaba mucho jugar
a rainbow six sin dejar a un lado sus
actividades cotidianas como estudiar o
pasar tiempo con su familia y amigos era
un chico sobresaliente cuando falleció
la noticia devastó sus familiares y
amigos tanto con uno de sus amigos hizo
lo posible para contactar a ubisoft y
contar la historia de boston peer you y
tratar de homenajearlo en el juego meses
después esto nos demos cuenta de que en
el mapa parque de atracciones había una
máquina arcade distinta a las demás en
esto estaba el hombre de boston vivir
junto con la frase siguió jugando por
siempre
[Música]
alan bartels es un gran fan de la saga
halo especialmente en los cinco este
hombre era muy feliz pero
lamentablemente sufrió una terrible
tragedia sus hijas trinity de 15 años y
linda de 12 años murieron en su hogar
debido a un incendio como era de
esperarse esto es juego hasta al hombre
y contra la tragedia se supo en red y
llegó adiós de la desarrolladora 343 no
tardaron en rendirle tributo a esas dos
princesas primero creando un emblema
gratuito llamado los espartanos nunca
caminan solos y además en un bello gesto
en un mapa del juego agregaron un
secreto muy especial dedicó a las niñas
nada así creando un precioso homenaje a
estas dos pequeñas que trágicamente nos
dejaron muy pronto logrando que cada vez
que el jugador bien las estrellas poder
los nombres línea y trinity en el
firmamento que los hombros saber que las
desarrolladoras llegan a tener este tipo
de detalles con los jugadores
[Música]
hace un tiempo miranda una madre dio a
conocer una historia en los foros de
everquest la historia a su hijo jon
también conocido como ribery de
everquest niño tan solo seis años quien
padecía el cáncer terminal y al que
lamentablemente le habían determinado
que tendría solamente entre uno o dos
meses restantes de vida
su madre al saber esto decidió hacer que
soy disfrutar al máximo el tiempo que le
quedaba y el ver que le gustaba tanto el
juego de everquest y los ya tan feliz
tomó la decisión de hacer un post
contando la historia su hijo jon y
viendo en la comunidad de everquest que
decoraron la casa virtual de jong con
árboles plantas y animales las cosas que
le encantaban ayón y cualquier otra cosa
divertida que le sacara una sonrisa al
ver esto la comunidad del juego
incluidos desarrolladores se lanzaron de
inmediato a dicho lugar para prepararle
la sorpresa con su padre capture momento
en el que ellos se encuentra con este
maravilloso regalo de la comunidad
sorprendido y muy alegre y el valiente
niño disfruta con todos sus nuevos
amigos que lo recibieron en su nuevo
hogar
[Música]
el 20 de mayo de 2012 su madre miranda
realizó una nueva publicación anunciando
que yo no había fallecido a la bondadosa
comunidad de everquest se le quedó
grabada la memoria recuerdo al pequeño
jon y desde entonces celebran eventos
anuales en honor al niño sé que esto no
es un interés pero quiero llegar el
primer puesto el pequeño john ese
valiente niño que con tan sólo seis años
y sin entender completamente su
situación nunca dejó de sonreír ya la
gran comunidad de everquest que hizo que
este niño fuera muy feliz
[Música]
visiten que ribéry
bien bien han sido suficientes lágrimas
de machos por hoy les agradezco por ver
el vídeo y si logre sacarte una que otra
lágrima que no sabe en los comentarios
hacer ese vídeo me costó bastante porque
es invasión de una garganta ambiente
necesitada pero si quiero no según
aparte venga dejaré al final en pantalla
un vídeo para que te alegres y puedas
ver mientras limpias tus lágrimas hasta
la próxima
[Música]